[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
we got with us christian today
finally we got christian in the hot seat
we're gonna get to learn a lot about him
as always we like to start things off
cold and then progressively the
questions get way way more personal and
intrusive i'm anti-mask
you can start with that
what else are you anti he doesn't like
the jabberwocky's mask
i'm actually anti-people join the club
dude all right that eliminates half the
questions let's start it off with uh
with the bart's coldest ice cold
question if you could redesign oh the
pine cone oh how would you make it look
make them hot pink hot pink is that your
favorite color yeah
since when
since oh man i don't even know is it
would you consider pepto-bismol hot pink
yeah that's like a pale pink that's yeah
that's like a that's an easy pink that's
a warm see my elementary school was
painted that color really yeah and so
was bart's dad's house but imagine if
like pine cones were just hot pink
though in the wild that'd be kind of fun
well that'd be pretty cool like just
randomly it'd be way more eventful you'd
like to be like oh look what's hot pink
like
like a fuchsia like uh
like it's a good rebrand like that like
the donut right there
that's light pink you gotta like turn up
the saturation huh yeah i think is like
uh maybe like this but it's like more
pink it's like yeah how do you how do
you know joe um i know joe through uh
through jump cut you remember that yeah
he was a student yeah a very successful
one and now a very successful channel
the whole origin of my channel was i was
watching in high school i was water was
in college it was one of those i was
watching jk news in the background and i
remember the specific video it was a
top
five most paid youtubers i don't know if
you guys remember doing that one but it
was like it was just actually just going
down the list of like the hottest
youtubers at the time and everyone was
making like an absurd amount of money
and it's like well you can get paid that
much doing youtube this is like during
like uh ryan higa michelle
fan days or no it's in 2016. it's like
pewdiepie
so we're talking about the the mega
successful youtuber i see okay you're
like pewdiepie and all them and at the
end of the video i just had playing in
the background when i was doing homework
and at the end of the video
you guys were talking about like oh
we're actually joining forces with kong
and jesse to do the jump cut course and
i was like in the middle of doing my
homework like oh man that sounds so much
more fun than this
so then i was like i'm just gonna do
that now that's gonna be my life like i
kind of just in that moment kind of
dedicated like when an athlete picks
that so it's like homework
or youtube
[ __ ] i'm just gonna do that and then i
did and then that was that's the whole
thing so this is kind of like a full
circle moment wow
that's so like cool life came from like
that episode now i'm on jk news it's
kind of like a cool
full circle moment what do you do on
your channel now i know men's fashion
but it's funny [ __ ] though dude he has a
lot of comedy oh yeah
he he did one about how to dress like a
[ __ ] dad how to just oh yeah how do
you rate bart's uh fashion
santa barb give him a give him a circle
around just so we can inspect you
what kind of t-shirts
and cargo pants but look at that fatty
though look at that fatty yeah but for a
dad though it's like popping not for a
dad vibe is pretty good
all right dad vibes is kind of like
that's a that's a uh that's like inspo
for a lot of people right now yeah
yeah like norm core is like a huge
really
cool what's that you know like what the
hell is norm core like you know when
people wear like dad shoes like the new
balances the white ones
and like wearing like a button-down
shirts like big button-down shirts and
like dad you know jeans that don't like
necessarily fit too well yeah like
wranglers or some [ __ ]
the original levi's people's muses right
now are their dads in new york come full
circle that's hilarious so like young
kids or young like hipster kids would
dress like that they if they dress to
look like they're not trying to dress
but still look kind of cool but yeah but
it's like their shoes are balenciaga and
it's just like
that's kind of like lauren's cow huh
shout out
what got you into fashion uh i think it
was freshman year of high school i was
like man all my friends are
cool and hot
i need a personality or something and
then you decided to make this your
personality i was like really fat in
high school and i was like man all my
friends are like hot they play football
and they surf i'm like i need a cool
thing dude like i need to keep up
somewhere so i was like i'm just going
to dress better than everybody was this
when you lived in hawaii yeah this is
what i look like because that's a weird
place to start fashion because the
fashion out there is like bikinis and
good bodies yeah yeah like there's a
board shorts and [ __ ] tank tops you
know what i mean like there's a big like
b-boy scene out there yeah so like a lot
of us there's a lot of street wear like
people like dunks and like sb's and all
that back then so i was like let me just
take see where this goes so it started
with like supreme and like nike shoes
and all that and then
slowly started realizing oh there's so
much more to this like rabbit hole so
i'm like on the internet just doing deep
dives i'm like going to school talking
about brands that people like who is
that person like who is that who's
christian deol yeah like who's that like
why do you care about that guy what's
some crazy brands that like are beyond
the surface that most people don't know
about
but like if you're in the in crowd oh
yeah like you're really into streetwear
there's a there's this
rick owens is like a big one like that
one's actually pretty mainstream now a
lot of people know about that one yeah i
know rick owens just hang on rico
[ __ ] no rick owens rick owens was one
that i was like man i can't wear this in
public why why just cause like if you
like hopefully the editor puts a picture
right now like like a rick owens runway
show like it's like
really
it's almost like art it's like how do i
wear this like how do i find an excuse
as to why i'm wearing it's like high
fashion stuff
do you have any rick owens clothing yeah
like in new york i have a i have a pair
of heels
that like they're like huge like six
inch heels for like guys and are they
hard to watch
yeah you get used to them they're not
that bad really do you think you could
like run like 20 feet in them oh they i
don't think i've actually i've tried to
run in them they're not that bad they're
like the
there's like it's like wearing a really
tall shoe as opposed to like a stiletto
like a
like oh it's like those shoes they used
to sell that help you dunk yeah yeah
yeah
but yeah fashion was definitely like i
don't know i think getting into that
was a
was that was my angle onto youtube isn't
that a very expensive thing to get into
oh definitely good write-offs though huh
everything's a write-off what's the most
embarrassing porno you ever jacked off
to
[Laughter]
speaking of fashion
and what were they wearing in it
like what did you jack off to you're
like oh man why did i do it to this one
definitely moments where like can't be i
didn't have like you know back then when
your phone didn't have internet or
you're just like man i gotta use my
imagination yeah there's definitely been
times right of make-believe yeah i've
been using my imagination and there were
times where i was just like nutted to
nothing
nothing you're like zen mud nutty
introspective i just gotta get a nut off
i'm like why did i do that you're just
not into like memory that's worse than
what you've seen that's pretty creepy
though i don't think i've ever seen
anything weird though i'd rather watch a
girl suck a horse's dick really did
nothing
yeah because you're just jacking off
into space there's no inspiration you
know what i mean i think i would choose
space over horse though space
to each of their own yeah don't yuck
each other's yums that's what we have
here i mean some of the weirdest porn to
jack off to stuff that's not porn at all
yeah
like what like a shape
like yeah like a sesame street episode
yeah
like a like a podcast
inauguration speech
i wonder if that's what designers
valedictorians yeah
they just [ __ ] they just jack off to a
sculpture of abstract art or some [ __ ]
like yeah i mean for sure it's like oh
that spherical shape isn't that a
universal rule everything's porn to
someone out there something a little bit
warmer for your space yeah uh
in in your
in your opinion which designer
is overrated it's overrated overrated oh
man
let's see it man i'm about to get heat
there's a bunch of people they're just
gonna be like
bless you
designer yeah there's no brand or
anything yeah that you're just like
something you shouldn't you can't say
eddie bauer okay yeah yeah
yeah i'm just oh phillip klein
you guys know phil phillip is like the
butt of the joke in all of fashion right
now why what's the what's this he sucks
what kind of stuff does he make oh man
he made a i'll tell you this this is
probably something that you guys like
maybe have heard about but like remember
when like when kobe died he made like a
tribute a tribute like line to kobe and
he and he like flew in on a helicopter
why to make a statement yeah
oh no that's really bad like a
helicopter or something around the it
was like part of the
design thing and people like oh i get it
it's to commemorate but it's like dude
what do you do bad taste
i don't get it did he consciously do
that to like i don't know he probably
thought it he probably thought he
snapped dude
he was popping off he's like oh they're
gonna get this one oh i love people like
that though they just don't get it and
they just [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] blow
their minds phillip line's like the butt
of the joke in fashion right now so
we're cool if we make fun of him
what a loser dude today's video is
brought to you by upstart saying goodbye
to high interest credit card debt is one
of the first steps to financial freedom
but the interest month after month can
feel like you're in this never-ending
hamster wheel that's where upstart comes
in upstair-powered personal loans can
help you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstart has
helped over 1.8 million customers find
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
you're more than just your credit card
score so rather than just looking at
your credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars without impacting your
credit score you can receive funds as
fast as one business day after accepting
your loan don't wait and check your rate
today at upstart.com off the record
that's upstart.com off the record to
check your rate today don't forget to
use our url to let them know we set you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com off the
record so you first got into like
streetwear right yeah and then
would you consider like yourself still
in streetwear or did you like go to a
different realm because i see like when
people get into art like they get into
like
the the usual craft and then the deeper
they dig
they start to become a trendsetter which
then becomes like they're too ahead of
the curve where they're wearing some
crazy [ __ ] like now they got [ __ ] a
bird's nest for a hat or like something
wild you know you got any birds nestled
hats that's what the question is
that's pretty as high fashion baby you
know i mean that's kind of like
[ __ ]
i think i'm kind of just all over the
place now because the nature of my
videos is i kind of talk about
everything so i kind of brush up on all
the genres of fashion and at this point
i'm kind of i like wearing ironic stuff
like
like this is a this is the shirt i'm
wearing right now what does it say
i just can't and it's an upside down
nike i just get
business too i love like boardwalk
t-shirts like stupid t-shirts i love
them
forever like souvenir shirts yeah
fbi female bodies
exactly that like like i went back
you get it gift shop t-shirt [ __ ] what
makes you like those so much because
it's like
yeah people think that it's ostensibly
bad fashion like oh it's like shitty
like i like wearing it now ironic like i
started wearing weed socks again yeah i
was about to that was my number two
being a [ __ ] troll i love
so everything you could get at hot topic
is like that's where you yeah man like
are you gonna bring back ed hardy though
dude ed hardy's like already on the way
back really
sequin shirts what about von dutch
dude dutch hats are like popping right
now i feel like meme culture has a lot
to do with current fashion yeah
i think i think it's just cycles yeah
and i think the cycles are coming back
faster and faster every time what's the
next fashion trend that you think is
like your fingers on the pulse what's
gonna be the new hot [ __ ] the 2000's
like uh
like um
like when you when you see like paris
hilton you used to wear and stuff like
that like and localized jeans yeah like
what nsync used to be wearing like rocks
like you're gonna see frosted tips
coming back like should have kept my
damn baggy pants you can hardly wait
like all the fashion there should we
frost our tips as a collective crew bro
[ __ ] man
the next three years you're gonna see
like frosted tips coming back like it's
already in new york upside down visors
and goggles oh dude in new york i'm
starting to see like oh what about
collars popped is that 2000's the
band-aids oh like a polo shirt yeah we
should all dress like our raving days in
high school like people wear oakley
shades now oh
are coming back you guys got to take it
one step ahead and start wearing the i
love boobies bracelets
oh yeah how can we find something we
gotta mass produce something crazy where
were they the lance armstrong
oh i started i started i don't have them
on me right now but i started wearing
those power balance bands again oh hell
yeah where do you find those now amazon
i bought a dude they used to be so
expensive i bought a pack of like six
for 10 bucks
yeah they used to be like 20 bucks do
people ever wear the uh
like the uh
i've fallen i can't get up bracelets as
fast life alerts
that's a necklace
i'm going to make a life alert chain
i'll send all you guys dude honestly
that'd be [ __ ] awesome that would be
so [ __ ] awesome with that right with
the red nuke button right in the middle
it doesn't call 9-1-1 it calls your
friend
how like damaging would that be if like
rape whistles became like an accessory
oh my god
honestly i don't think it's a bad idea
honestly i mean
it functions if it functions it's like
why not just keep it on yeah just keep
one on you i think so like do you guys
like all my friends carry like pepper
spray in new york we just carry guns bro
i think you should carry a knife
what's the deal with fanny packs people
make fun of me for wearing a fanny pack
how are you feeling and i've been
wearing that [ __ ] before it started it's
so straight in the middle
i don't know i just made that up
it's two right down there you gotta wear
it hip-hop to this just a little bit to
the side dude i like wearing on my head
i love fanny packs so it's okay you you
approve i get the christian these fanny
packs like not a thing in new york now
people wear them but people like wearing
them actually in new york right now like
actual just side bags are big
just like how do you feel about that
what's your take on sidebacks i love
them
yeah guys wearing like purses is big in
new york right now yeah i've been seeing
that a lot wow
fashion is so androgynous like yeah it's
like not so defined you know do you go
to like the new york fashion week paris
fashion week like all those yeah i if i
get invited i like sometimes i'll get
invited sometimes they're just like
actually he talks too much [ __ ]
when you see the met gala what do you
think of when you see that do you think
that's too much or do you think it's
like yeah
what would be your met gala outfit my at
is actually vans at the met gala because
i want to go because you know it's like
people wearing crazy ass [ __ ] i want to
pull up wearing vans authentics
what is your take on the current fashion
trends in albuquerque new mexico
that's the hottest question of the night
dude like the jesse pinkman
yeah
okay bounder rvs the jed the people in
new york are actually starting to dress
like jessie pingman
oh yeah that's like 2 000 oh yeah guys
that actually like
out of style because people are like
running that down oh they're just going
overboard with it yeah with like the
osiris shoes oh yeah the big ones the
big goofy ones green steve's going to be
in style soon you've got the
oscillations would you say uh new york
is america's fashion capital oh
definitely why not anchorage alaska
you know what they probably got some
rare vibes out there that's true it's
very very different i thought it was
temple city was it difficult for you to
uh leave uh the island and go to a big
city and and and explore did you feel
like a farm girl moving to the big
[ __ ] city honestly i was surprised at
how
the big [ __ ] city do you feel like a
little farm girl
we do a big city big [ __ ] city
[Laughter]
i was surprised how seamless the
transition was yeah really yeah like i
just pulled up and within the first day
i was like
oh [ __ ] like because i was here at the
time before i moved to new york i was in
alhambra and i was like oh la's cool you
know i'm like not crazy over but i'm
like i guess the whole fall in love with
the city thing is like a myth or
whatever that's like all in movies and
then i visited my friend in new york and
i was like oh this is how it's supposed
to come that's a city la's not really a
city
ellie's a big fuck-off suburb yeah
too big yeah it's massive and like in
new york you can do like multiple things
in a day you can like meet up go get
lunch whatever go work out whatever in
la it's like you pick one thing and you
commit to that yeah that's all you do
that's true
you gotta come you gotta drive an hour
there you might as well stay there for
like four hours because yeah for 30
and take an hour back in new york it's
like oh yeah i'll be there in like 15
minutes
you know
so it's like i think
the pacing is different and the
lifestyle is different but i feel like
they're special in their own way are you
gonna stay in new york for the rest of
your life you think definitely until
like
definitely until i'm old or something
until i like settle how do you feel
being away from all your ohana on the
island i try to visit once a year oh
really whenever i go back at least now
i'm like realizing oh it's when i visit
my parents it's harder to leave them
every time my business oh
my gosh they're getting to that age
where i'm like man there's only be so
many of these left you know when i go
yeah that's true damn being so far is
definitely becoming more and more of a
like a liability than i thought it was
because when you're young you're like
dude [ __ ] them whatever yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm away from my parents but now
i'm like they just visited me so
they came to new york yeah what's the
most disappointing thing you
did in your parents eyes most
disappointing thing dude it's still
dropping out dropping out of college do
they still complain about that
what was your major when you dropped
like i don't care if you're a
millionaire
oh okay yeah i was you dropped out of
community just first semester i finished
my first semester and i was like
i'm not finished you could show them the
video and be like mom these are the guys
that helped me drop out oh yeah i'd be
like they support it did they go to
college
yeah yeah uh both my parents graduated
also they're not hypocrites then all
right they're not hypocrites
i wanted to drop out too my dad even go
to high school i'm a [ __ ] you
finished high school then that's why i
tell my parents
yeah you could have finished high school
you got kicked out trying to make me do
something you didn't even do
yeah no i still also get the question
they still mention like oh are you gonna
go back oh dude oh do they think you're
just [ __ ] around and hanging out in
new york and not doing [ __ ] with your
life they're just like so like after
this youtube thing like what's up i'm
like i don't know why don't you become a
doctor oh no
oh wow yeah like you're going to run out
of money i'm like dog i hope not that's
the whole thing
that's the whole plan mom
i hope
did you think you're just buying taco
bell all day and [ __ ] just [ __ ] doing
nothing with your life you're like are
you okay i'm like yeah i'm fine i'm fine
they still ask me like do you need money
i'm like no i'm good i promise guys just
gotta open up your bank account and be
like mom do you want to go on a vacation
yeah dude i asked him i was like i
always ask him like
we'll go to the north shore have you
ever been there
they have this thing where it's like
they think
[Laughter]
they think i'm broke and i'm rich at the
same time oh that's what does that mean
they're like are you okay to eat money
i'm like no i'm good so when are you
gonna fly us out
it's one of the it's a test dude it's a
test they have they have to always ask
if you have money or not i think you do
you have any major regrets
of of of life yeah decisions you've made
or now we got to turn up the heat
at the very last moment
i don't think so because i always think
like oh that happened so that this could
happen and without i always like in my
head try to convince myself whenever
something's bad but you kind of know
some of those didn't need to happen huh
and what were they
but
like did you ever have a friend give you
a ride and like six people die
[Music]
yeah ever yeah that ever happened
we're just asking all your friends are
in life
[ __ ] serious
i regret not taking part in that what
the [ __ ]
that's a anime story yeah that's right
maybe you're one of my curses i heard a
bunch of small [ __ ] that i can't find
excuses for him like if i lost a like if
i lost like a watch or something like
[ __ ] bro there's no life lesson here
i just [ __ ] misplaced it yeah like
like if i do something bad like if i
miss a huge opportunity i'm like all
right well that's probably needed to
happen so that something cool could
happen but if it's some small [ __ ] like
i forgot to like forgot my wallet i'm
like this there's no life lesson here
it's time to get a chain wallet so it's
stuck to you yeah
yeah two thousands fashion yo come on
full circle get it with the metal beads
and [ __ ] you know
i regret like small things though
definitely not the big stuff what are
some small things yeah like losing my
wallet
that's pretty regretful move yeah like
why did i do that or like
getting my getting like my order wrong
at starbucks or something your own order
yeah
you got your own order this is stupid
or like when you get something you try
something for the first time in its ass
and you're like oh why did i do that
that's that's a true regret or barista's
telling you uh that's wrong why did you
say that that's not what you get that is
the ultimate regret
your life seems pretty good man
[Music]
you